It seems that we've moved away from introspection and I think we are finding
that the short term stimulus are pursuing sense pleasures is not making up for
the increasing hollowing out.
I think of people's inner experiences.
Yeah.
Well two things that that you said there that that that struck a chord with me.
The first was that
with regards to external stimulation,
the question is is that if you're continually bombarded by the outside world,
it's telling you what to do all the time.
I gather people are always telling you what to do when they talk to you.
And of course advertisers and social media are really like seriously and
explicitly telling you what to do.
And the question is,
well,
how do you decide what you should do for you?
And the answer to that is that you have to consult yourself.
And unless there's time to do that and you consult yourself partly through the
use of your imagination,
daydreaming and daydreaming about what the future might hold and then actually
consciously thinking about it in planning.
But you need to disconnect yourself from the external stimulation in order to do
that.
And it might take some time and so yes,
I think that we're in danger of losing now.
I think children are in danger of having their play interfered with two and we
don't know what the consequences of that would be,
but I don't suspect that it will be the too much of that will be,
well,
if that happens to to graded degree,
the consequences will be negative.
And you also mentioned prayer,
you know the,
the cynical attitude towards prayer is something like asking God for favors.
And then of course the cynical analysis of that is that if you ask God for
favors,
like he won't help you find your lost wallet,
generally speaking,
you know,
but that isn't,
if you're,
if you take a bit of a more sophisticated approach to it,
you know what you're doing.
If you pray,
we could even,
we'll seem to find that more acceptable is that you,
you formulate a question and you,
you wait for an answer.
Like a prayer might be,
okay,
I would like to do the best thing I could with my life.
Now you have to open yourself up to that.
That's to knock.
So the door will open.
I would like to do the best thing with my life.
What might that be?
Now you could say that you're thinking,
when you say that are you are,
you could say that you're leaving yourself open for a revelation or an
intuition,
but you're communing with whatever it is that enables you to receive wisdom.
And you can attribute all of that to you,
or you can attribute it to your brain,
I suppose,
but you're,
you're really communing with the structure of the cosmos when you're,
when you're asking such a question,
and especially if you do it properly and it's really useful to do that and it's
really necessary because it orients you properly.
So yeah,
the demise of prayer when prayer is considered in a sophisticated manner,
which is do I commune with the better part of myself,
let's say,
to determine how I should orient myself in the world?
It's a catastrophic loss not to do that.